[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen im Sport schauen wir
natürlich unter anderem auf die
Fußballfrauen WM dabei ein schönen guten
Abend als erstes blicken wir aber auf
den verzweifelten Kampf gegen die Brände
in gleich mehreren Ländern
Feuersbrünste rund ums Mittelmeer in
Algerien sterben mindestens 34 Menschen
und auf Rhodos heizen starker Wind und
extrem Hitze die Flammen immer weiter an
ein Land in Aufruhr Israelis aller
Bevölkerungsschichten laufen weiter
Sturm gegen den Umbau des Justizsystems
ein Hügel im Umbruch zur Eröffnung der
Wagner Festspiele in Bayreuth gibt es
erstmals virtuelle Elemente und auch das
überrascht sogar noch Karten
[Musik]
seit Wochen herrschen sehr hohe
Temperaturen in der Mittelmeerregion
viele Wälder sind bereits ausgedörrt und
dazu kommen noch starke Winde das Fach
die Feuer weiter an und so werden immer
neue verheerende Brände gemeldet aktuell
sind die Feuerwehren in mehreren Ländern
im Dauereinsatz über die Brände auf der
griechischen Insel Rhodos berichten wir
ja schon seit Tagen auch in Süditalien
und Tunesien gibt es größere Feuer und
in Algerien starben bei den Waldbränden
schon mindestens 34 Menschen über die
Lage dort in Arbeit ist
hier ist das Feuer bereits vorbeigezogen
für einige kam es so schnell dass sie
nicht mehr wegkamen 34 Tote gibt es
bisher im bejaja östlich von Algier
sterben zwei Familien
fünf Leute waren in diesem Auto und in
dem hier Vater Mutter und fünf Kinder
aus Algier hier sind insgesamt 12
Menschen gestorben
die Handy-Videos der Algeria zeigen ein
furchtbares Bild an der gesamten
Nordostküste bis hin nach Tunesien
brennt ist eine nie dagewesene
Hitzewelle die Temperaturen lagen seit
Tagen bei rund 50 Grad
1.500 Menschen mussten in Sicherheit
gebracht werden manche können nur noch
das blanke Leben retten dieser Tourist
sitzt mit seiner Familie auf einem
felsenfest
die Hitze ist unerträglich der ganze
schwarze Rauch und die Asche kommt auf
uns zu ich habe versucht wenigstens die
Kinder zu schützen
8000 Retter sind im Einsatz Winde fahren
die Brände immer wieder an aber auch
wenn alles gelöscht ist in vielen
kleinen Dörfern haben die Bewohner alles
verloren
ich habe noch nie so ein Feuer gesehen
das ist nicht normal wir sind einfach
nur weggerannt
immer noch Kinder helfen nach Angaben
des algerischen Innenministeriums sind
inzwischen 80% der Brände unter
Kontrolle und die Temperaturen in der
Region sollen langsam zurückgehen
von Nordafrika jetzt nach Griechenland
der starke Wind ist dafür verantwortlich
dass die Feuer auch auf den Inseln immer
wieder außer Kontrolle geraten ob Rhodos
Korfu oder albeur es besteht weiter
große Gefahr Alexandra Vacano berichtet
immer wieder neue feuerfronten wir sind
im Krieg so beschrieb es gestern die
Regierung der Feind die Flammen für die
die gegen sie kämpfen ist es
lebensgefährlich auf der Insel stürzt
ein Löschflugzeug ab Pilot und Copilot
überleben den Absturz nicht
das Feuer ein Albtraum für jorgios Papa
Georgio sein Café in Kiotari auf Rhodos
völlig zerstört
es ist eine große Katastrophe unsere
Geschäfte sind ausgebrannt jetzt
brauchen wir positive Energie um wieder
von vorne anzufangen wir haben die Kraft
die lösch-profis im Dauereinsatz aber
sie kommen nicht hinterher deshalb
versuchen auch viele Einheimische und
Touristen irgendwie die kleinsten Feuer
oder Glutnester zu löschen selbst mit
nassen Handtüchern
Maria padalu von der Feuerwehr sagt die
Leute hätten alles verloren ihre Felder
ihr zu Hause das Krisenmanagement des
Staates eine Schande
jedes Jahr sagen sie wir werden die
Dinge besser machen es passiert nichts
jeden Sommer das gleiche
es hört nicht auf es gibt kein Ende
dieser Tragödie wann wird das Aufhören
wo ist die Hilfe
sie bräuchten noch mehr etwa 150
Quadratkilometer Wald sein bislang
zerstört worden so erste Schätzungen die
Brände sie treffen Griechenlands wichtig
so Branche so wie dieses 5 Sterne Hotel
in kyotari einige Gäste die von hier vor
den Flammen geflüchtet sind holen heute
ihre Koffer und die Crew des Hotels
fragt sich wie es weitergeht sie sagen
ohne Tourismus haben wir kein Leben
vor allem die Feuerwehr aber auch viele
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner wir haben es
gerade gesehen versuchen zu löschen
Andreas
wie kommt der Kampf gegen die Feuer
voran
hier dieser Ort malonas an dem ich stehe
in der Insel Mitte in der östlichen
Insel Mitte ist heute gerade wieder
aufgefordert worden von der vom
Katastrophenschutz den Ort zu evakuieren
die Menschen sollen den Ort verlassen
und ein Anwohnerin sagte mir hier ganz
entnervt das ist das zweite Mal dass sie
jetzt in Folge 48 Stunden hier ihren Ort
ihren Haus ihr habt und Gut verlassen
müssen um sich vor den Bränden die hier
hinter mir wieder aufflammen in
Sicherheit zu bringen das zerrt an den
Nerven die Einwohner sind hier über die
Tage hinweg wirklich nervig sehr sehr
angespannt und die Löschflugzeuge die
hier den ganzen Tag über geflogen sind
haben diese Brände einfach nicht in den
Griff bekommen fünf weitere Ortschaften
sind jetzt aktuell evakuiert worden und
die Löscharbeiten gehen weiter voran vor
allen Dingen aufgrund der starken Hitze
und des starken Windes der hier nach wie
vor weht auf der anderen Seite der Insel
im Nordwesten da sind die Touristen
weiterhin im Urlaub und bekommen von all
dem gar nichts mit und das ist ein
zwiespältiges Gefühl denn natürlich
braucht diese Insel den Tourismus und
auf der anderen Seite hier im Südosten
der Insel kämpfen sie um Hab und Gut
eine gute Nachricht gibt es heute aus
Rhodos nach den siebten Tag in Folge
sind aufgrund der frühen Evakuierung
bislang niemand zu Schaden gekommen
auch auf der italienischen Insel
Sizilien gibt es heftige Waldbrände in
Norditalien dagegen schwere Unwetter
zwei Menschen kam ums Leben vor allem
die Regionen Lombardei in Venetien sind
betroffen Hagel Sturm und Starkregen
führten auch in Mailand zu überfluteten
Straßen und Kellern in der Altstadt
musste das Wasser abgestellt werden
bereits am Wochenende waren mehrere
Regionen in Norditalien von Unwettern
heimgesucht worden
nachdem Israels Parlament ein
Kernelemente umstrittenen Justizreform
verabschiedet hat wächst auch im Ausland
die Sorge so sagte Bundesjustizminister
Buschmann dem Spiegel Israel war immer
eine Leuchtfeuer für Demokratie und
Rechtsstaat im Nahen Osten viele Freunde
Israels haben die Sorge dass dieses
Licht nur nicht unbedingt heller scheint
in Israel selbst gehen die Menschen
weiter in Massen auf die Straßen von
dort berichtet Stefanie
in der Nacht gingen die Proteste weiter
in Jerusalem aber vor allem in Tel Aviv
gewaltsam als jemals zuvor dutzende
Demonstranten werden verletzt für Israel
eine sehr hohe Zahl abschrecken lassen
aber wollen sie sich nicht ihr Kampfes
Wille ungebrochen
wir geben nicht auf wir werden weiter
kämpfen unsere Kinder wachsen hier auf
und wir werden es nicht erlauben dass
eine Gruppe von Kriminellen die
Regierung übernimmt und sie machen
können was sie wollen ich bin sehr sehr
enttäuscht als Konsequenz haben meine
Freunde mein Partner und auch ich
gestern Nachrichten an unsere
Kommandanten geschickt dass wir nun
nicht mehr freiwillig bei Militär als
Reservisten dienen werden
für Israel Sicherheit und verzichtbar
denn sie verstärken die Armee nach
Bedarf dazu kommt die Frage in welche
Richtung sich die Proteste bewegen
Israelis bei der Lager fürchten eine
weitere Zuspitzung die sogar
wahrscheinlich ist
was wir gerade erleben ist eine
Eskalation von Spannungen dieser der
Gründung des Staates angewachsen sind
wir sehen eine politische und soziale
Krise dazu kommt dass die beschlossenen
macht und der Gerichte durch die
Regierung wohl nur ein erster Schritt
war in ihren Plänen für die Justiz
ein erster Streit gegen diese am
Vormittag im Gesundheitssystem
Krankenhäuser waren nur minimal besetzt
eigentlich sollte dies 24 Stunden
andauern doch die Regierung wandte sich
an die Gerichte diese verboten den
Streit als unrechtmäßig
Israel kommt nicht zur Ruhe einen Tag
nach der historischen Entscheidung in
der Knesset
wie kommt das Getreide aus der Ukraine
auf die globalen Märkte darum geht es
heute beim Treffen der eu-agraministerin
und Minister in Brüssel seit Russland
das getreideabkommen aufgekündigt hat
ist der Export über das Schwarze Meer
nicht mehr möglich die EU könnte helfen
doch die hatte Einschränkungen für
getreideimporte verhängt um die eigenen
Märkte zu schützen diese gelten bis
Mitte September
Polen Bulgarien Ungarn Rumänien und die
Slowakei wollen auch danach an den
Beschränkungen festhalten Isabel
Schäfers
der slowakische Landwirt Duschen Knatsch
baut vor allem Raps und Weizen an ca 50
km entfernt von der ukrainischen Grenze
er leidet unter gesunkenen Preisen und
fehlenden Abnehmern für seine Ware der
Grund immer mehr ukrainisches Getreide
kommt in den östlichen grenzstaaten der
EU an
das ukrainische Getreide wird nicht
einfach durch unsere Länder hindurch und
weiter nach Ägypten und Afrika
transportiert sondern es bleibt hier bei
uns und dadurch ist bei uns der
Weizenpreis gesunken
ein Dilemma für die EU denn sie will die
Ukraine unterstützen ihr Getreide
vermehrt über den Landweg durch die EU
in die Welt zu bringen noch einmal mehr
seit Russland den getreidedeal gekündigt
hat
wir wollen der Ukraine helfen aber eben
unter solchen Bedingungen dass keine
Schwierigkeiten auf dem Markt für die
slowakischen Lebensmittel entstehen
um das zu erreichen bekommen die
Betroffenen osteuropäischen Bauern
derzeit Ausgleichszahlungen und die
einfuhr-ukrainischer Produkte in die
betroffenen Staaten wurde beschränkt
aber die Regelung läuft bald aus und die
Ukraine fordert eine vollständige
Öffnung der EU-Grenzen für ihr Getreide
absolut jede Verlängerung der
importeinschränkungen des absolut
inakzeptabel und ganz klar uneuropäisch
und so sucht die EU nach Lösungen die
beide Seiten zufriedenstellen das
Problem ist lösbar man könnte
beispielsweise dafür sorgen dass die
Produkte aus der Ukraine verplommt an
die Häfen transportiert werden
beispielsweise im Baltikum und dann
dorthin transportiert wird was benötigt
wird in den globalen Süden es bleibt ein
Balanceakt zwischen Solidarität mit der
Ukraine und dem Schutz der europäischen
Märkte
in Moskau hat das russische Parlament
die Obergrenze für Einberufungen zu
Militärdienst angehoben von 27 auf 30
Jahre die Änderung tritt zum
Jahreswechsel in Kraft außerdem dürfen
Wehrpflichtige Russen nach der
Zustellung des einberufungsbescheids das
Land nicht mehr verlassen
Wehrpflichtige werden offiziell nicht
ins Kriegsgebiet geschickt es gab aber
immer wieder Berichte über ihren Einsatz
in der Ukraine
Cera Verteidigung wird die Ukraine ja
intensiv mit Panzern Waffen und Munition
unterstützt auch aus Deutschland
entsprechend ist die Nachfrage bei der
Rüstungsindustrie groß allen voran bei
Rheinmetall zumal ja auch die Bundeswehr
ausreichend ausgestattet werden soll
damit das Ganze auch möglichst schnell
geht müssen die Rahmenbedingungen
stimmen Markus wollhöfer und Peter
Theisen berichten
bei Rheinmetall in Kassel spüren Sie was
zeitenwände heißt plötzlich werden ihre
Produkte wieder anders gesehen volle
Auftragsbücher Rekordumsätze und zuletzt
gar der Prestige Aufstieg in den Dachs
seit dem russischen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine boomt die deutsche Rüstung
Industrie sie hofft viel abzubekommen
vom 100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen
von der wirtschaftlichen Seite her ist
es so dass es Rheinmetall gut geht das
ist ganz klar aber wir haben natürlich
in den letzten 25 Jahren viel zu wenig
gemacht für die Sicherheit unserer
Länder die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie
zusammengeschrumpft in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten und das macht heute Probleme
denn die Bundeswehr hat ihre
Beschaffungsstrategie geändert die
Beschleunigung militärischer
Beschaffungen ist mit sofortiger Wirkung
handlungsleitend das
Verteidigungsministerium will vor allem
Markt verfügbare Produkte alles was
schnell lieferbar ist doch darauf sah
die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie bisher
schlecht eingestellt sagen Experten
die Industrie reagiert was macht sie
jetzt sie baut ihre Kapazitäten auf und
sie erweitert das bisher eigentlich enge
Produktportfolio um innovative Elemente
und für die Bundeswehr schnell Produkte
liefern zu können ein hohen Nutzen
fähigkeitszuwachs und gleichzeitig
natürlich unternehmerische Chancen zu
realisieren dazu gehört mehr
Internationalisierung Rheinmetall plant
etwa eine Panzerfabrik in der Ukraine
und in Deutschland da hoffen auch Länder
und Kommunen vom rüstungsboom zu
profitieren für uns ist Rheinmetall
natürlich als Land ein wichtiger
Arbeitgeber aber natürlich auch ein
enorm wichtiger Wirtschaftsfaktor
spätestens bei den Zulieferern für
Getriebe Optiken Module mischt sich die
militärische mit der zivilenindustrie
die zeitenwände so die Hoffnung soll
auch Konjunkturmotor für den Mittelstand
werden
der internationale währungsform blickt
mit Skepsis auf die deutsche Wirtschaft
er hat seine Prognose zur Entwicklung in
diesem Jahr erneut abgesenkt die IWF
fachleute erwarten einen Rückgang der
Wirtschaftsleistung um
0,3%. damit ist Deutschland der einzige
G7 Staat für den der IWF die Prognose
von früher nicht angehoben hat
Sommer blauer Himmel für die
Photovoltaik sind das beste Bedingungen
samstag der 8 Juli war so ein top-tag
für den Solarstrom rund 32 Prozent der
gesamten Stromerzeugung kam dabei uns
aus der Photovoltaik wenn wir aber auf
das gesamte letzte Jahr schauen betrug
der Solaranteil nur
10,9%. deshalb soll mehr Fläche für
Solarmodule her auch in der
Landwirtschaft Jan Meyer berichtet
klimaschutzminister Harbeck besuchte am
Nachmittag eine Versuchsanlage in
Rathenow in der Rinder bereits unter
Solarpaneelen gehalten werden für
Viehzucht ist genug Platz unter
Photovoltaik in über 3 Metern Höhe sie
produziert bei Sonne Strom und bietet
Schutz bei jedem Wetter nicht nur für
Kühe sondern auch für Hühner und Gänse
das Forschungsprojekt zeigt wie
Landwirtschaft und Energieerzeugung auf
einer Fläche möglich sind
die produzieren genauso viel Strom wie
normale Solaranlagen aber haben noch den
Effekt dass unter dem Modulen
Nahrungsmittel angebaut werden können
oder Tiere sich wohl fühlen und auch
weiden können sogar Tomaten reifen im
Schutz der lichtdurchlässigen
Solardächer die jedoch fünf Mal mehr
kosten als herkömmliche Anlagen eine
solche Investition überfordert viele
Landwirte auch wenn die
Einspeisevergütung für Solarstrom
deutlich erhöht wurde
eine agrypv-anlage ist natürlich um
einiges teurer im Invest als eine
standardfreiflächenanlage und deswegen
brauchen wir hier auch ein Bonus im
erneuerbaren Energien gesetzt damit
diese Sache überhaupt richtig in Gang
kommt doch heute in Rathenow machte
Minister Habeck wenig Hoffnung auf neue
Förderprogramme ich sehe auch umgekehrt
eine Nachfrage nach agpv und wir müssen
jetzt diese kritische Schwelle
überspringen und dann glaube ich gehen
auch die Kosten für solche Anlagen
runter Minister Habeck will den Anteil
der Solarenergie bis 2030 verdreifachen
dazu soll der Bau von agris Solaranlagen
einen Beitrag leisten
heute ist ja der 25 Juli und das heißt
traditionell Eröffnung der Bayreuther
Festspiele mit roten Teppich und viel
Prominenz allerdings ist dieses Mal auch
einiges anders so wird die
Opernaufführung paar sie Fall durch
virtuelle Elemente ergänzt die das
Publikum mit Spezialbrillen verfolgen
kann und für die Festspiele die
eigentlich immer ausverkauft sind gibt
es überraschend noch Karten Barbara Look
über das weltberühmte Opernfestival
auf sie ist Verlass
Premieren Rausch mit Platzregen und
Sturmböen
[Musik]
diesmal schreiten sie eine Revolution
entgegen versprechen die Festspiele
[Musik]
Parzival digital das Bühnengeschehen
wird dabei mit Hilfe von sogenannten
ar-brillen durch virtuelle Welten
ergänzt
die Idee spektakulär nur es gibt viel zu
wenig Brillen kein Geld da die
allermeisten sehen diese Revolution also
gar nicht sondern lediglich das bunte
Bühnen Treiben der Regisseur hofft nun
auf Nachschub
wir beten für mehr ich denke aber dass
die Menschen in den nächsten Jahren ihre
eigenen Brillen haben
schlechtes Management was ist los am
Hügel hinter den Kulissen brodelts
interne quälen verworrende Strukturen
Traditionalisten im Clinch mit Reformen
zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte sind
die Festspiele nicht ausverkauft zum
Leidwesen der Chefin Katharina Wagner
und zum größten Glück der Fans heute
morgen ergattern Heike und Thomas Vogel
noch zwei Premierenkarten
für heute Abend Wahnsinn wirklich total
aufgeregt
vielleicht wird dies ein Schicksalsjahr
für die Bayreuther Festspiele ein Jahr
der Veränderung
der Erneuerung
ob Katharina Wagners Vertrag verlängert
wird ist völlig offen aber die Botschaft
ihres Urgroßvaters ist überall spürbar
Kinder schafft neues
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen wir zur Fußball-WM es
war wirklich ein toller Sieg der
deutschen Frauen gestern und beim
Publikum haben sie auch super anders
über 5,6 Millionen Zuschauer sagen das
Spiel bei uns live im ZDF 60%
Einschaltquote am Vormittag das ist ganz
stark nächsten Sonntag der nächste
Gegner Kolumbien andere Klasse als
Marokko doch jetzt heißt es erstmal für
das DFB-Team den Sieg genießen
das Ende einer erfolgreichen Dienstreise
die Rückkehr ins Mannschaftshotel
schmucklos aber mit einem Sieg und
schönen Erinnerungen im Gepäck
tat gut mit der ganzen Mannschaft so
zusammen zu singen und ja den sie
einfach zu genießen da hat auch gut
sechs Tore und vor allem dieses
kopfballkunststück von Alexander Popp zu
feiern doch Marokko soll nur ein erstes
Ausrufezeichen gewesen sein
wir sind froh dass wir so gut das
Turnier gestartet sind aber wir sind uns
bewusst dass jetzt noch sehr sehr
schwere Spiele Folgen werden die Hände
hochgesten sollen sich wiederholen schon
am Sonntag gegen Kolumbien morgen liegen
die dfb-frau und dafür erst mal die Füße
hoch
ja und Kolumbien hat heute sein erstes
Spiel verdient gewonnen 2:0 gegen
Südkorea zunächst verwandelte Katalina
usme in der 30 Minute einen Handelfmeter
9 Minuten später dann die Entscheidung
durch Linda Kai Sedo allerdings mit
Unterstützung der südkoreanischen
Torfrau
die anderen beiden Spiele heute
kogasgeber Neuseeland unterlag den
Philippinen mit 0:1 die Schweiz und
Norwegen trennten sich 0:0 bei der
Schwimmbäder in Japan ist Florian
wellbock nach dem Doppelgold im
Freiwasser heute im Becken über die 800
Meter frei steht schon im Vorlauf
ausgeschieden besser lief es dagegen für
isabellose
Vereinskollegin durfte sich über eine
persönliche 1500 Meter bestseits freuen
eine Medaille war damit aber dennoch
außer Reichweite Platz 6 für isabellose
dem Feld weit entfernt waren in der
us-rekordweltmeisterin Katy der Decke
der Umstieg vom Freiwasser ins Becken
ist Florian wellbock offenbar nicht
bekommen als Fünfter seines Vorlaufs
reicht es am Ende nicht fürs Finale nur
710 Sekunden fehlten
er hat gar nicht in seinen Rhythmus
gefunden also wir normal schwimmt und
ist sehr sehr aufwendig geschwommen mit
Lukas Mertens links im Bild erreichte
wen noch ein deutscher Schwimmer das 800
Meter Finale
WM 2019 auch die 800 Meter Freispiel
verpatzt und danach die 1500 Meter
geworden schauen wir mal am Wochenende
ja genau
morgen wechselt sich blaue Himmel mit
kurzen Schauern und Gewittern ab mehr
zum Wetter gleich von Christa Orden
Dunja Hayali begrüßt sie um 21:45 Uhr
zum heute journal bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend ja zu uns ist jetzt für
diese Jahreszeit richtig kühle Luft
eingeflossen mit Werten von nur noch um
20 Grad im westlichen Mittelmeer gehen
jetzt morgen die Temperaturen mal wieder
auf ein Normalmaß zurück mit um 30 Grad
aber im östlichen Mittelmeer gibt es
auch morgen wieder Temperaturen über 40
Grad hier gibt es die Entspannung erst
am Ende der Woche bei uns wird es heute
Nacht schon kühl es kühlt ab auf 14 bis
7 Grad oft ist es einstellig vor allem
im Bergland und dabei singt sogar die
Schneefallgrenze auf 2000 Metern das
heißt in den Hochlagen der Alpen schneit
es heute Nacht bis zu 10 cm sind möglich
für alle anderen im Süden und im
Südosten bleibt es bei diesem teils mal
kräftigeren Regen anfangs mit Gewittern
zum Morgen hin bilden sich dann auch
kurze Gewitter im Nordwesten und das
geht dann eigentlich morgen für den
gesamten Tag überall wechselt sich der
blaue Himmel mit kurzen Schauern und
Gewittern ab am wenigsten davon gibt es
Richtung Osten hier ist die Luft noch
trockener und dazu wird frischer
Westwind
dieses wechselhafte Wetter das kommt
durch eine Abkühlung in den höheren
Luftschichten zustande und das merken
wir auch am Boden nur 15 Grad in
Richtung Alpen 22 Grad immerhin in der
Niederlausitz und eine Spur wärmer wird
es erst zum Wochenende es bleibt aber
wechselhaft tschüss